House of the Dragon, a Game of Thrones prequel
show, is coming in 2022 on HBO
and Targaryen dragons are coming with it.
It will feature around 20 dragons and in the
part 1 I covered many of them.
We start part 2 with the most beautiful Targaryen
dragon, Sunfyre.
Sunfyre, known as Sunfyre the Golden, was
the mount of Aegon II Targaryen during the
Dance of the Dragons.
He is one of the dragons HBO shared in their
announcment few days ago.
According to some sources, Sunfyre was the
most beautiful dragon ever seen upon the earth.
Sunfyre had gleaming gold scales and his flames
were golden as well.
During the siege of Rook's Rest, Rhaenys Targaryen
arrived riding the large older red dragon
Meleys
to attempt to lift the siege of the castle.
This was all a trap, however, as the Greens
had kept two of their own dragons hidden and
in reserve so they could take Meleys in an
uneven fight.
Aegon II appeared riding the younger but strong
Sunfyre, and his younger brother Aemond Targaryen
also attacked riding the massive Vhagar, last
of the first generation Targaryen dragons.
Rhaenys could not prevail against such odds,
yet she did not flee but flew head-on to meet
her attackers.
Meleys was still so large and powerful that
she put up a brutal fight.
When the dust settled Meleys was dead and
Vhagar was relatively unharmed, but Sunfyre
had been nearly killed and permanently maimed.
Meleys managed to nearly rip one of his wing-arms
completely from his body, and as for Aegon
II, he was left horrifically burned and with
multiple broken bones.
Sunfyre survived the battle but the world's
most beautiful living dragon was left crippled
and heavily scarred, just like its rider,
Aegon.
Aegon and Sunfyre reunited at Dragonstone.
When Sunfyre arrived he fought and killed
a remaining riderless dragon, Grey Ghost - though
he took yet more wounds in the process.
When Aegon finally rode Sunfyre again, he
was attacked by Daemon's young daughter Baela
riding the dragon Moondancer - an even younger
dragon barely large enough to carry the 13
year old girl.
Moondancer was quick, however, while Sunfyre
was still half-crippled and slowed by his
injuries.
They were therefore evenly matched and their
duel was ferocious.
It culminated when Sunfyre tackled Moondancer
in mid-air and drove her into the ground below:
his larger size meant that he survived the
fall while she was killed.
Nonetheless Sunfyre was mortally injured by
this fight, and would never fly again.
Sunfye died soon after.
Despite being one of the younger dragons in
the Dance, Sunfyre actually shared the highest
dragon versus dragon kill count with the massive
Vhagar herself: two individual kills and one
assisted.
Both Sunfyre and Vhagar died as a result of
their third dragon fights.
For that matter, they were the only two dragons
in the Dance who ever lived through a dragon
versus dragon fight and lived (most dragons
in the war were actually killed by human armies,
or died in mutual kills in their first battle
against another dragon).
Next we have Stormcloud who was a young male
dragon bonded with King Aegon III Targaryen.
Aegon used Stormloud to escape an ambush at
the sea.
Prince Aegon managed to reach Dragonstone,
clinging desperately to his dragon's neck.
Stormcloud had been terribly wounded as he
fled; when he arrived at Dragonstone stubs
of countless arrows were embedded in his belly,
and there was a scorpion bolt through his
neck.
Stormcloud died within an hour, hissing as
the hot blood gushed black and smoke from
his wounds.
After Stormcloud's death, Aegon would never
fly again.
Now we come to the most epic, strongest, fiercest
and battle-hardened dragons:
Daemon's Ceraxes and again Aemond's Vhagar.
The other dragon HBO teased in thier announcement
was Daemon's Caraxes.
Caraxes was the dragon ridden by Prince Daemon
Targaryen during the Dance of the Dragons.
A veteran of many battles, he was known as
the Blood Wyrm for his red scales.
Caraxes was one of the older and larger dragons
during the Dance of the Dragons.
Daemon Targaryen rode Caraxes in his frequent
campaigns in the Stepstones.
As a result Caraxes was not only one of the
larger dragons during the Dance, but the most
battle-hardened and experienced in war.
Indeed, only Vhagar had ever been ridden in
major wars before, during Aegon's Conquest
but while formidable, Vhagar had not been
used in combat in the years leading up to
the Dance, the way that Caraxes was.
Opposing armies were known to often simply
flee or surrender when Caraxes approached.
When Rhaenyra captured King's Landing in a
surprise attack, Daemon rode Caraxes in the
assault while Rhaenyra rode Syrax.
Later in the war, Aegon II's younger brother
Aemond Targaryen resorted to a one-man war
riding Vhagar, burning out much of the Riverlands.
Daemon hunted him for a long time on Caraxes,
aided by other dragonriders and their dragons,
but eventually he returned alone to Harrenhal
waiting as a challenge for Aemond to arrive.
Caraxes was formidable but Vhagar was twice
his size, nearly as large as Balerion had
been during the War of Conquest.
Facing him alone was the only way for Daemon
to draw Vhagar out, however, as Aemond had
avoided ambushes by multiple other dragons.
Aemond arrived, exchanged his final challenges
to Daemon, then both took to the air on their
dragons.
The resulting Battle Above the Gods Eye was
one of the most epic dragon-versus-dragon
fights of the entire civil war, as two of
the greatest living dragons fought in the
air.
Their shrieks shattered every remaining window
in the castle and could be heard for miles
around.
Their fire-breath filled the sky so that fishermen
in the lake thought that the whole sky was
aflame.
In the end, Caraxes dove down from the sun
on Aemond's blind side (due to his missing
eye).
Caraxes slammed into Vhagar and they both
continued to fight in free fall.
Vhagar tore out Caraxes's belly, and used
her massive jaws to rip one of his wing-arms
completely off - but Caraxes sank his teeth
into Vhagar's throat and maintained a death
grip.
As the two dragons grappled, Daemon rose from
his saddle and made a stunning mid-air leap
from his dragon to Aemond on Vhagar's back.
Wielding the Valyrian steel sword Dark Sister
(which had once been carried by Vhagar's previous
rider, Visenya Targaryen, Daemon thrust his
blade through Aemond's empty eye socket - the
force of his impact as he landed driving the
sword through the back of Aemond's head.
Both dragons plummeted into Gods Eye below.
Both dragons and both dragonriders died.
By the end of the Dance in 131 AC, only four
dragons remained alive:
Sheepstealer, the Cannibal, and Silverwing,
who had been born years before the war,
and the dragon Morning, which had hatched
during the war.
In other words, only one dragon who fought
during the Dance of the Dragons, Silverwing,
survived.
Dragon Morning was born after the war, while
the other two,
Sheepstealer and Cannibal were wild dragons
that lived on Dragonstone.
Sheepstealer was a wild male with a taste
for mutton.
The smallfolk of Dragonstone named it for
a self-evident reason.
Sheepstealer's coloring was an ugly "mud brown".
He was not aggressive toward human unless
provoked, but could be vicious and ill-tempered.
He had a taste for mutton.
While he devoured an occasional sheep dog,
he never harmed a shepherd.
The Cannibal got his name for practicing cannibalism,
feasting on dead dragons, newborn dragons,
and dragon eggs.
He was one of three completely wild dragons
dwelling on Dragonstone.
The Cannibal was black as coal, with menacing
green eyes.
He was the largest and oldest of the wild
dragons.
That's all that was left of 20 dragons that
Targaryens had had just a year and a half
ago.
And they would soon die as well.
Archmaester Marwyn, holds that the order of
maesters,
with their secret goal to suppress magic,
was responsible for the extinction of dragons.
The word is that they poisoned the last of
the dragons.
There were still many dragon eggs left after
the war, and at least one of those hatched.
The last dragon was a sick and misshapen thing,
and she died young, in 153 AC, during the
reign of King Aegon III Targaryen, which earned
him the nickname Dragonbane.
She had been a green female, small with withered
wings.
Many futile attempts were made to revive dragons.
Aegon III Targaryen, the Dragonbane, had nine
mages cross the narrow sea to use their magics
in attempt to hatch remaining dragon eggs.
The pious King Baelor I Targaryen attempted
to hatch his egg by praying over it.
Aegon IV Targaryen ordered pyromancers to
build seven mechanical "dragons" that shot
jets of wildfire.
Hundreds of men died in a failed attempt to
use them to invade Dorne.
The tragedy of Summerhall resulted from the
attempt of King Aegon V Targaryen to hatch
dragon eggs.
The Mad King pretended he was a dragon, using
wildfire to burn his enemies and believing
he would become a dragon after he dies.
None of these attempts brought dragons back
until Daenerys.
Ultimately, the reason Targaryens lost their
dragons and thus their power was the Dance
of the Dragons.
So many dragons had died in the war that the
Targaryens couldn't maintain a stable breeding
population, and the few survivors became inbred
and sickly.
Fortunatlely, however, the key event of House
of the Dragon is the exact same event which
led to their extinction - the Targaryen civil
war, the Dance of the Dragons and we'll get
to see them all on screen.
A lot of dragons, a lot of epic dragon battles,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel series, House of the Dragons brings
in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters, the mighty dragons
and their epic battles in the comment section
down below.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!